well the commissioner Andy Rowe has
tonight told Sky News that he is
horrified by what has been laid bare in
this report put together by Nazir afsal
who has spoken to 2 000 staff or former
staff at the London fire brigade and
they have given him a catalog of
horrendous racist bullying misogynistic
behaviors that really uh have fested
within the London fire brigade and some
of the examples are just quite
jaw-dropping as you say a mock noose
being put above the locker of a bullied
black firefighter in London a Muslim
firefighter who was being vilified
because of his faith who had a bacon
slice put in their sandwich that he was
about to eat and then female
firefighters reporting horrific examples
of sexism and misogyny within the force
one female firefighter telling the
report that you would actually have to
gouge someone's eyes out to get sacked
because everything else in her words was
just banter tonight as I say we have
spoken to the commissioner of the London
fire brigade who has been imposed for
two years Andrew Rose says that he
commissioned this report he suspected
that there was a problem but the level
of the problems that have been outlined
in this report have horrified him they
bring shame upon the fire brigade and
that they need now to show real courage
in facing this and the kind of Courage
that of course firefighters show every
day in their jobs needs to be applied to
the change that is necessary within the
London fire brigade this is what he told
me a short time ago
you know it's a shameful day for the
London fire brigade I'm horrified I know
that many of my staff decent
hard-working public servants will be
horrified by what they've read the most
terrible examples of bullying and
harassment
um and this has to act as a catalyst for
absolute change and that change has to
start now
the London mayor Sadiq Khan has echoed
those calls for Change and has expressed
his horror at the findings of this
report and has backed the commissioner
to continue with the process that his
role shouldn't necessarily be uh
questioned in the in this process
because it is he who after two years in
the job has identified these problems
and has now exposed them through this
report by Nazir afsal who also found
that there were real deterrence of
course to people staying within the
force if that is the culture that people
are having to work uh within whether
they are from an ethnic minority or
whether they are LGBT Plus or another
minority someone who for whatever reason
has been bullied within the fire brigade
and he also points out that while this
is a cultural problem it is
significantly different perhaps to the
problems within the Metropolitan Police
and as much as this hasn't necessarily
led to misconduct in office it has just
been an appalling culture that has been
laid bare there and the changes that are
being brought about now will start
immediately to bring about the kind of
scale of change that is needed to
address this problem that has been
exposed so vividly tonight